>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michael Apfeldorf: Now
I have the great pleasure
to introduce our next
presenter, Herve Tullet.
Herve is an award winning
author and illustrator
of more than 20 childrens books.
And he is considered one of the most
innovative childrens authors today.
Born in Normady, he has
lived in Paris France
and today he makes his
home in New York City.
Herve started his career
as an art director
in advertising and communications.
Then after the birth
of his first child,
he decided to become a
childrens illustrator.
Eventually he took on the
role of author as well,
which is helped him achieve
his own unique style.
Since then his works
have been translated
into 25 languages worldwide.
Some of the titles you might
recognize are Press Here,
The Big Book of Art, I am Blop
and Let's Play Games
series of board books.
His most recent work is Let's Play.
Herve also leads workshops for
children all over the world
in which he helps them to unlock
their own creative energies
through art.
Like many of you I
have had the pleasure
of reading Herve Tullet's
books with my children
and enjoying how unique they are.
We have particularly enjoyed not
just reading them, but being able
to play with them as
physical objects.
For as many of you know with Herve's
books you're frequently invited
to take action.
This could be as simple as pressing
a dot, to see what it will do
or it could be drawing on your
fingers and using them as characters
in the book or any number of things.
Either way Tullet's books invite
children to become active partners
in creating their own unique
experience with books.
And as a parent and an educator
I really appreciate this.
So with that please
do help me welcome,
author illustrator Herve Tullet.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Herve Tullet: Thank you.
Okay.
Hello.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Hello. Ah that's better.
Hello.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Okay. Hi. Hi.
Hi. Okay. Mmm.
Miam. Mmm.
Miam. Uh oh.
So it's for a reason most
terrible reading, I have all done.
I need you.
Mmm. Miam.
Mmm.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
So uh oh was good.
We need to work.
Okay one more time.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
There all definitely is the best.
But [inaudible] where okay, maybe
we could try something is to grow
up the sound as the
fish is growing up okay?
Got it? Participate.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
The oh oh is really perfect now.
So now we're doing a
big mmm and a big miam
at the end and I stop boring you.
Participate.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
That's the best one.
Thank you.
Oh! Ah! Whao!
Waf! Waf! Super!
Oh Senior!.
Oh la la! Bravo!
Bravo! I do it again
because of the bravo.
Oh! Ah! Whao!
Waf! Waf! Super!
Oh Senior!
Oh la la! Bravo!
No I don't think the bravo, no, you
were very good with bravo, yeah, no.
I notice you're very helpful.
We do it again because
of the bravo again.
Oh! Ah! I just go straight
to the bravo.
Whao! Waf!
Waf! Super!
Shine! Oh la la!
Oh la la! Oh la la!
Oh la la!
[ Multiple Speakers ]
That's good one.
Very strong.
I do it in French for you.
[ Foreign Language ]
I would like to hear a big
traffic jam, one, two, three.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Oh you is the police okay you can
do what you want to do, I know.
Uh oh. Do you know I was a car we'd
go from this side to this side.
Jump. One more.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
She [foreign word] water.
I like it very much.
Another idea?
>> Back up and then run
as fast as you can, jump
>> Herve Tullet: Back up go
back to the book again that way.
I translate for you, she goes
that way and you go that way,
you jump down and it's all right.
So this is my work, my
work is to find ideas to go
from this side to this side.
This is my work.
I'm looking for different
ways, different ideas.
I list them and when I found one
which to me sounds
the best, I keep it.
But with a pen you know you
can do what you want to do
which is very convenient
compared to reediting.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Background Sounds ]
It's actually something
[inaudible] you know.
[ Foreign Language ]
There's only one person
who is follow me.
In Japanese that's only,
Japanese language speaking.
[ Foreign Language ]
Who want to read it
in English for me?
>> Me.
>> Herve Tullet: You, okay come on.
Wow. Oh my god.
[ Background Sounds ]
Okay. On the floor.
Okay come on.
Could you, no, no, no stand up.
Stand up on the floor.
Show me your voice.
>> Hello.
>> Herve Tullet: Very good voice.
Okay she's the master, you know the
[inaudible] it's very simple look
at me, look at me.
Hello. Hello, hello.
[ Inaudible ]
Crazy huh?
Now very good.
Okay let's do it.
[ Inaudible ]
This one is very easy
you know you would.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Stop.
Stop, stop, stop.
[ Background Sounds ]
That's enough.
Stop buzzing me.
[ Background Sounds ]
Do you understand?
Stop it!
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Herve Tullet: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Another one?
You want to do it?
Okay come on.
I do it if you will.
Come on, come on, come
on whoa, whoa, whoa.
You're tall you can do it.
>> Stand on the chair.
>> Herve Tullet: Okay let's do it.
[ Background Sounds ]
Very well okay, thank you.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Oh.
Stop it!
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Stop it! Go away!
Do you understand?
>> Herve Tullet: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
It could last for hours you know.
Okay, that okay?
The mic, okay?
Get it? You get it good?
Wow. Blop.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Blop. Blop.
Blop.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
It's a way to keep the
control on the audience.
You know.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
So I've got something.
How do you translate blop?
Please teach me blop.
>> Just spell it.
>>Herve Tullet: Just b.
>> B.
>> Herve Tullet: B.
>> L.
>> Herve Tullet: L.
>> O.
>> Herve Tullet: O.
>> P.
>> Herve Tullet: P.
>> Herve Tullet: P. Okay.
Can I read to you?
At the same time of course.
Blop. Blop.
Okay.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
For those are prompts, please.
You can't read these?
No, okay.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Only one. Always the same one, she
speaks Japanese, she speak blop,
she doing everything you can
upload, say thank you to her.
[ Applause ]
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Okay.
I know.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Thank you.
Thank you, stop it.
Stop blop.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Who want to help me
to read that book?
>> I want to read it.
>> Herve Tullet: Come.
>> I will.
>> Herve Tullet: You will?
Okay come on, okay.
[ Background Sounds ]
You're tall.
Okay on the chair.
You know everything
about that book already.
It's called, Mix It Up.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
You know people are
looking at us [inaudible].
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
No you're put finger on it.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Not seeing it, do it better.
>> Beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep.
>> Herve Tullet: Now it's better.
Colors are coming, one more time.
No.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Ah colors are coming, that's good.
One more time.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Here they are.
No, no it's not always the same
thing you know you have to change.
You have to change,
we put your hand on,
you close your eyes, we count five.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
You've got a magic hand.
>> Wow.
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah, you
can do it with that too.
I've got ten minutes left so.
Where's your magic and you
know what you're going to do?
You are going to take some blue.
Boom. You know what's
going to happen?
>> No.
>> Herve Tullet: No?
>> Green, green, yeah green.
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah.
And if you take some red?
You know what's going to happen
if you put it on the blue?
You know.
>> Purple.
>> Herve Tullet: Ah ha.
And if you take some yellow?
You know what's going to happen?
>> It's going to become orange.
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah so you
know everything about colors huh?
So you take the book, you
take it, you take it, take it.
Take it.
>> Take it.
>> Herve Tullet: You just take it.
>> Okay.
>> Herve Tullet: Take it,
please take it, take it,
take it, take it, take the book.
They are not use to take
the books that's why.
You take it, you take
it and you shake it.
>> Shake it?
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah.
>> Does it mix together?
>> Herve Tullet: You know
what's going to happen?
>> It's going to mix
together and make green.
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Herve Tullet: And
if you tilt the book.
You know what's going to happen?
I'm the page turner.
You don't turn the page.
>> Okay.
>> Herve Tullet: I turn the page.
>> Herve Tullet: I've done it.
>> Purple.
>> Herve Tullet: Yes and
if you shut the book.
Yeah one more time.
Okay. You know what's
going to happen?
You know? Yeah and if you
[inaudible] the book, one more time.
Okay one more time, you
know what's going to happen?
There's some more treats
but five minutes left.
So you just put your hand on it.
[ Background Sounds ]
And your hand is not magic anymore.
Thank you.
Bye, bye.
[ Applause ]
So we want to read maybe a
small, this very small one.
Oh you told me, it doesn't matter
the five minutes left you told me.
We want to, okay, okay.
Wow. That's a challenge.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, you help, if you
want to come, you come.
[ Background Sounds ]
Camera please.
Okay on the floor.
>> You ready?
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Herve Tullet: Uh oh.
>> Uh oh.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Herve Tullet: Uh oh.
In five minutes he should sleep.
[ Laughter ]
In France we started
in pharmacy you know.
Very very convenient, you should
buy it actually gets out of print.
[ Background Sounds ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Woo. Very last book, come on.
Okay. Okay.
Come on. Ah, you've got
the torch I love it.
It works? We don't
know does it work.
>> It does.
>> Herve Tullet: Oh wonderful
you know I've got a book
and sothat we can do
it, you know you play
with shadows just like
that you know.
With your torch, you are putting
shadows on the wall or on your face.
[ Background Sounds ]
Does it work, oh yes.
Okay. Okay.
Okay but, oh nice.
Okay, okay [inaudible].
You stop with the torch, it's okay.
Turn knobs off.
It's all right, it's all right.
Okay wonderful.
Okay. What's your name?
>> Ben.
>> Herve Tullet: Ben,
Ben you press here.
Here. We have to, no
one more time more.
Press, yes very good,
one, two three.
Uh oh. Thank you.
Thank you.
Press here again.
Yes. Uh huh.
Uh oh. Thank you.
It's my son.
We know each other very well.
Gently. Yes, yes, yes, yes, uh huh.
Uh huh. He's very good.
Is he expensive for,
does he travel or?
Okay just one jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump, uh huh.
Uh huh. One, two, three, four, five.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Uh huh. Uh oh.
[ Laughter ]
This one. One, two,
three, four, five.
One.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Uh huh.
[ Background Sounds ]
And the last one.
One, two.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Uh huh. Uh oh.
Uh huh. Take the book.
Take the book, you take the book.
I mean you're English?
We get along very well together.
You shake it.
Uh huh. One, two, three.
[ Background Sounds ]
Could you shake it harder?
I'll help you.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three.
Uh huh. You take the book
and you tilt that way, yeah.
Uh huh. Uh huh.
The other way around.
Uh huh.
Uh oh. And you shake the book
to put everything back in order.
Absolutely.
Show it to me.
Wonderful, now you can
press on the yellow dots.
[ Background Sounds ]
Uh huh.
And, yeah I know, I know
it's good, yeah I know.
And now you turn on the lights.
Just press somewhere
to turn on the lights.
Yes, uh huh.
Uh oh. I know you, we can
press on all the dots.
[ Background Sounds ]
Uh huh. Wow.
And now you can shake the book.
Yes. Uh huh.
Uh huh. And now we can blow
to get rid of the black.
Wow. Uh huh.
Uh huh, maybe a little
bit more here.
You do it perfectly, everything
is just, is it a robot?
We can, we can no?
We can program it for different.
>> I am a robot.
[ Laughter ]
>> Herve Tullet: To much, help
me to let them going down.
Good in English, yeah.
One, two, three, one, two,
three, one, two, three, uh huh.
Yeah, and maybe now all
together we can clap once.
[ Background Sounds ]
Twice. Three times.
More. More.
You press here and
that's it for today.
Woo.
[ Applause ]
Thank you it was amazing.
Enough for today.
That's okay, you want to
question or something like that?
No. No you have a question for me?
You want to, you want to, read
a book, okay, okay lets do it.
I mean there's a lot,
there 80 books.
So you want to read it?
Okay. Ready?
You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Herve Tullet: He's ready.
In this book it's little dots.
On to move away and to
go the end of the book,
so in order to do it you
press, you press, no, no,
no you don't, no it's another trick.
You press here, here.
Yes. And you will go here.
And now you press here.
And it will go.
>> There.
>> Herve Tullet: There.
And if you press in
the middle, it will go.
>> In the middle.
>> Herve Tullet: Exactly,
in the middle.
So now the dot can move, so
now what we have do is just
to follow the line with your finger.
You follow the line.
Whoa, whoa, we can go
faster there is no limits.
Speed limits.
There is no speed limit
and the book is quiet long.
Whoa, one more time.
[ Background Sounds ]
You could help me.
Whoa where are you?
Oh wow. One more.
[ Background Sounds ]
It's always like that.
I like it.
Wow. Very nice and now we can go
on and do and do and do swisping.
One on the yellow dots.
[ Background Sounds ]
Wow. Wow, uh oh you
changed all the colors.
Now we can jump on the yellow dots.
[ Background Sounds ]
Where are you?
One of the red one.
Yeah. Who's speaking in the
mic, oh you don't know me too.
[ Background Sounds ]
Great. We go on, go on,
go on, go on, go on.
I tried [inaudible] the
mic and play with it.
Oh, uh oh you want
to play game with me?
>> Yeah.
>> Herve Tullet: What do we do?
What about hide and seek?
Hide and seek okay.
Uh oh where is the dots?
>> Yellow dots?
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah
the yellow dots.
It's tricky, no this
one is to big no, no.
It's, yes okay.
So we go on, we go on, we go on,
we go on, we go on, we go on, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And we go on and we're
going into the tunnel,
you want to go into
the tunnel with me?
Yes, you want, you want.
Okay go on, go on, go on that's
on the next page you have
to go very very, very, very
carefully because there is
so we are going to do, to go and
teach you choo, choo, choo, choo,
choo, choo, choo, choo,
choo, choo, choo, choo, choo.
Sorry it's not [inaudible] you
are not authorized to do it,
but I like it, it does it from here.
Are you able to do one more time?
I like it choo, choo, choo.
That's all right the
second time you don't.
Okay, okay, okay, go,
go, go, go fast, go fast.
[ Background Sounds ]
Woo again.
You don't want to go on that page.
So you put your hand
on, you close your eyes
and we say twice za, za, zoom.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
And it will disappear because
you don't want to go inside that
but you have, just to dirty.
Yeah it's to dirty, where
is these and not on the page
and to make it appear again you put
your hand on you close your eyes
and you say again za, za zoom twice.
And the dot is here.
Yes, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Looks like, you know
what you have to do,
you have to press really
hard on the dot.
One, two, three.
Oh almost, one more time.
[ Background Sounds ]
Really really hard.
Wow. Oh my god, where's the dot?
It's on your head.
Yes. It's on your head, it's crazy.
It's all right, it's all right
you just shake your head,
shake it and the dot is back.
Wow wonderful.
And now that's it we can go.
>> We?
>> Herve Tullet: We,
we you and me go.
No, no, no no questions.
No Q and A. Gone, I know
there's some trick but.
Yeah, okay he want
to finish the book.
Yes and you turn and
you jump and you fly
and that's the end of the book.
Thank you, you were amazing.
Woo.
[ Applause ]
That's the ah you.
>> Can I read a book?
>> Herve Tullet: Can
you read a book?
Of course you can.
Of course you can read a book.
We've got one hour left.
They changed all the rules.
>> Can I read a book now?
>> Herve Tullet: Yeah,
yeah we close in one hour.
We close in one hour.
Security, okay.
You want to me turn
the page for you.
You won't mind?
Okay. You want to me
leave or to stay here?
>> Stay here.
>> Herve Tullet: You stay here okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What are you doing?
>> Reading.
>> Herve Tullet: Really.
Okay, one more, one more okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I think they are sleeping now.
>> Oh.
>> Herve Tullet: They are
sleeping, they are leaving,
they are leaving, they are leaving.
>> Stop.
>> Herve Tullet: They are leaving.
Okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay that's it for today.
>> Okay.
>> Herve Tullet: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.